[Music]
in rags to riches news thanks to [ __ ]
submitted by monopack a student went on
a 73 day shopping spree after
accidentally receiving a million-dollar
steal loan pay out dumbass used to pay
that back idiot what kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] does take 73 days how much money
did you use or she that's what I want to
know it sounds like uh I don't get
trouble Chinese who some reason I think
he's trying to get Chinese it sounds
like a [ __ ] he you know why
because girls I think yes they they
can't control themselves and they want
to spend but they're still like this
this motherly instinct in their mind I
go don't do that
no guys they usually don't spend as much
as girls do but then when they get their
hands on money they turn into little
[ __ ] because I remember an old story
just just leave it there he said
actually he actually said something nice
about women oh I always something Julia
Julia's fair dude I'm being fair okay go
because it's like it's nice that you
would say that which I always do by the
way and I'm just saying that there's
there's a very few females that just do
really poorly like they just do wrong
and so like there's one time we talked
on JK news where this chick she got a
[ __ ] ton of money like wired into her
bank account older son realized it and
she spent it all what she Latin no I
think shows
so now you're gonna talk [ __ ] about that
no I'm just trying to make sure of the
facts what we're just they knew it was
11:00 okay thank you
if a million dollars showed up in my
account I'm spending I'd be like this
this is dangerous - I gotta return this
- I'm disappearing
I would withdraw it [ __ ] buy a plane
ticket go somewhere else and destroy all
my identity million God Hey a million
dollars in Vietnam oh my god you're a
billionaire
yes [ __ ] die [ __ ] for a
lifetime this is how terrible I am at it
one time we got to check for $800 mailed
to me mm-hmm
I was like what the [ __ ] what it was a
company that was familiar it seemed like
a gig that I work in the past and I
called I was okay so I got this check
for like 800 and they pretty much check
it they're like oh [ __ ] we sent our
accent oh my God we're so sorry
thank you so much for cashing it like
all right and I hung up and only escaped
money a million dollars skates like I'm
[ __ ] out [ __ ]
for a million bucks dude I'd be good for
the rest of my life the way I live that
means yeah the way I don't live
expensive I can't do it yeah so sorry
part you were wrong I knew it oh it's a
Qi mom her name is Sid vongole girls
can't control themselves that's what I'm
trying to tell hey she's just one of the
very few that's like spreading a bad
name to help his case yeah so she's 27
years old from South Africa and instead
of what her 108 monthly cheque that she
gets from student aid a hundred and
eight turned into a million dollars it
turned into a hundred and eighty
thousand no wait sorry $1,080,000 Oh
someone put some extra zeros huh yeah I
put four extra zeros the [ __ ] intern
typed it wrong
yeah what do you think like no one's
gonna notice and it was incoming she
should've took that money out and
disappear yeah how is she ever gonna pay
that bad
funkin escaped to the Galapagos case you
returned everything we did she spend it
all within the 73 days so she just went
on a 73 day spending spree but she
didn't spend it all she ended up only 16
what she spent $65,000 just such a
spending so she was spending her money
on she was blowing about eight hundred
and sixty dollars per day that so she
was she she started raising eyebrows
when she started sporting a 230 builder
Peruvian weave and then she started
wearing designer outfits she bought a
brand new iPhone
she began flashing cash to her closest
friends she stalks up to get new outfit
and don't was [ __ ] have $65 bottle and
whiskey while they would jet around the
country and attend wild parties a $65
bottle of whiskey is not I could only
think like a good Joe and at the top of
my head is worth 13 I had that money
what would have given me away is when I
started riding a camel to school where
the [ __ ] that market that camel [ __ ]
with the cloth outfit with the glasses
[Music]
looking like a Saudi Arabian solid gold
traipse in account I just the face
things making yeah out of all the
animals you chose to like ride you to
school you chose account camels are
regal as [ __ ] Hamels are cool you can't
put a tiger monkeys okay I'm probably
gonna go with the [ __ ] not even a
white stallion basically no one's gonna
notice you you're gonna have a [ __ ]
horse and no one's gonna blame Oh Jimmy
got a million dollars yeah she's like
she's gonna get Loki gonna be like get
all that money she's still she's still
chopping be from their [ __ ] front
lawn with a [ __ ] cleaver
in my [ __ ] Honda Element would you
ride on it though would you ride on the
top portion of the neck all the way down
on a saddle if it doesn't harm the
draught totally on the top oh my god you
get to hold the [ __ ] little nubs I
totally do that so anyways yeah she
finally got out stood by a deputy branch
security of the South African Student
Congress but before that no conscience
our suspicions were growing about her
because there was a local convenience
store receipts that leaked online
showing that she had a 1 million and
$50,000 in hurt oh we see like a big ATM
receipt a convenience store maybe
there's an ATM the funny thing is it's
not accounting that caught it no people
that was laughs this [ __ ] too poor to
have that much money haters
no one noticed me you know if yeah if
she didn't spend like that and show off
maybe she would have got away with it
yeah yeah she should have just hired
some old guy just him up to look all
fancy and pretend that that was her
sugar daddy and then no one would asking
anything no she's not tricky just
probably modest for until I was out of
college yeah you should still go you
surprise birthday parties for her
friends and flying them everywhere and I
just yeah I tried to all that giving I
would like to be her friend that's true
yeah cuz she didn't just spend it all on
herself she's flying all her brand new
Gina hmm you always say you'd buy us
each a helicopter yeah if it was like my
real money everyone would get hurt on
this everyone would get a helicopter
with their face painting in the front of
it you know that you're gonna fly in and
then the tail of yours gonna be a giant
ball team yeah
these sprinkles I hang on all your
peoples their eyes burn and [ __ ] no
science I want people to burn I'll just
be like that guy's gonna have his own
little mini helicopter he's so cute
though the smallest helicopter it's like
a drone this is like such a [ __ ] girl
conversation right now that's right each
other David's helicopter doesn't want it
you can have everything that was gonna
give David fine what am I gonna do why
are you like 42 Honda elements that's
what I wanted about cars though if you
get more of the same one it doesn't
really help
yeah it doesn't yeah the Saudi prince
arimathea whatever prince and i met with
like five Bugattis dude y'all probably
different though didn't look like the
same color the same everything color
yeah that's like having why have
different ones dude yeah there's two
I'll give you every color of the rainbow
there's two vehicles that are really
really really well spelled what am i
regatta it's the Honda Element I haven't
done everything I wanted to it we're
just not gonna be expensive anyways and
I also want the the VW s or the surfer
man [ __ ] is hella expensive really it's
a classic
it's a classic so if you get it in good
condition I'm talking about where you
could still run it and have it run well
it's like the cheapest one that I found
without having to do too much to it was
about 40k but it's a great condition
though but if you want to put the work
in you want to do the body what a fix
the engine like some of this [ __ ] - like
the axles all busted all this other
stuff all these issues
it'll still be about 20 G's so it's not
a cheap [ __ ] you know
color EGS we want those bright pastel
color we'll probably get it in like
yellow and white oh is it the one we
took a B in the front it's like a
different color yeah yeah actually
that's a dope man C if I was rich I
would buy you that you over here being
my don't know why I like these obscure
like [ __ ] deflecting vehicles just get
yourself a PT Cruiser go on today that's
like the ultimate loser doesn't have
great utility like all these vehicles
like you continue literally sleep in it
not the Prius anymore it's a little too
slow but she was very right yep
which one the classic yeah but that's
just a [ __ ] sleeping bag it's dope put
your [ __ ] surf bottle surfing [ __ ]
but you guys want to surf and you gotta
hang lights on the inside or so worried
I don't even do that I've never seen
that car drive up to snowboard here it
is the classic Beach yeah yeah I just
like I just like vehicles like that all
my life yeah so anyway this chick she
said quote today my personal life has
become a social media scandal I have
been named and shamed in public today I
am a bad person a person who stole the
money of students with that being said
and being named a thief but as we all
know in every story there is truth and
there are lies with the very same story
when you stole the money why she's just
being randomly vague for yourself
besides it is very clear that I didn't
make the error but every story there are
words and adjectives and verbs but it is
reported that she will have to repay the
money obviously the least it's only 65
grand she has to repay because if she
was any of us and we blew it all yeah
that's a lot of money to repay for a
long time yeah there was like a
spokeswoman saying that um that that
million dollar payment didn't affect
other students but it did just come from
having a lot of people being angry
because there was a shortage of funding
recently in the student payments and
they're like in this [ __ ] gets a
million
right so someone had to have gotten
fired for this mistake and not seeing it
for so long
yeah a million twenty good luck with a
million dollars my life doesn't change
much it's just now I have some money to
clean my house when I was getting ready
this morning funnily enough funnily
funnily enough you don't funny enough
funny enough it's not funnily enough the
word funnily fu and and il ugly look up
that word is that one le where'd you
learn that word oh that's the word
funnily oh yeah it sounded being correct
rub it in Gino yeah thinking this
morning that sound like a word so
funnily enough so funnily enough I was
reading this morning cuz I have someone
over at my house cleaning right now I
was thinking to myself I wonder if
Tiffany in case like this was a thought
well let's do make up for some reason
yeah I wonder if Tiffany and Casey
actually clean up after each other or
they have someone to clean because their
house is so clean whenever I come over
oh how much does it cost for a cleaning
person it depends on who you go to
ah depends on the place I mean it
depends on the person but usually the
police depends on the person but the
person that I get is a rat for the hole
for the whole house yeah they kill it do
they're amazing I've gone through so
give me that no I'm so tired of cleaning
my place cuz I'm being a lot for my
house I'll give you the number I have
Mariel talks in because I always be
Chinese okay thank you very much yeah
have a Chinese person but and they come
in 45 minutes
dare you come in and come out
so good I love because your place has a
lot of floors to just like I don't
they're really fast they're really good
no they're mean I have like this gay
black guy that comes in and like we
talking we gossip all the time and he's
amazing and he's so sweet I don't wanna
get rid of him is cleaning good he's
[ __ ] amazing dude
like this whole doesn't just clean he
organizes everything boxes he's like
I'll put ties everything for you like
he's amazing he's doing I love you
because clean is a strength I mean
they're like tidy things up like put
things like in a nice corner do laundry
I see my dude does like my dude does
like laundry he doesn't have it if you
asked him to
it'll be additional feet do they wash
your dishes cuz they don't watch my
looks are like barbecues or in the
summertime yeah I always tell you guys
don't help clean because I just call the
next day yeah my dude [ __ ] does all
the laundry washes folds puts it away
hangs up all my stuff he's like
organized all my makeup and [ __ ] no man
thing am i keeping yeah I usually keep
up here what's up you sexy [ __ ]
useless [ __ ] [ __ ] if you
want to follow us you could check out
all our [ __ ] links in the description
box below you [ __ ] [ __ ] and then
that videos are up there